let me ask you a question what is growth  for you is there a way for you to Simply  explain why is it that humans are so  obsessed with the idea of growth and  progress there are two reasons for that  one is overt and the other one is  covered the overt reason is that from an  objective standpoint growth offers a  level of options that allow the  individual to live more comfortably  within the premises of society the  converted reason is that growth is the  only available mechanism known to man  that can help us reach  self-transcendence I hold the belief  that we have reached a point in history  where the progress of technology has  surpassed our ability to follow that  progress as a result we are trapped in a  very limited apparatus called human body  that makes our symbiosis with technology  quite frictional initiatives that focus  on ideas like AI Singularity and any  other way that can allow humans to  experience self-transcendence and need  growth in order to materialize